let me be clear there's no room
uh in our classrooms for things like
critical race theory
teaching kids to hate their country and
to hate each other
is not worth one red cent of taxpayer
money
florida governor ron desantis blasting
critical race theory
banning it from the new statewide civics
curriculum
desantis echoing former president trump
when making that announcement this week
so should that be a model for the rest
of the country
joining me right now is florida
republican congressman byron donalds
congressman it's great to see you
tonight
thanks so much for joining us not only
are you a congressman
from florida but you are a father of
three in school
your reaction my reaction is simple
governor desantis is absolutely correct
what we want to make sure we do is
understand that our children are taught
the full history of the united states
and yeah we have dark spots in our
history i'm the first to acknowledge
that
but we also have to understand that our
country is the great story of redemption
in world history we are a far better
country than we were
100 years ago 200 years ago and we need
to embrace
our history but also and understand and
embrace the country we are today
and the country we continue to become
every single year going forward
so i applaud the governor and his
decision we need to see more of that in
the other 49 states
right on i want to ask you about
education in general
because the two sides have a completely
different approach
to education we all know that many
parents who are watching us tonight
may very well not have their kids in
school because we're waiting for schools
to open we also know
that the democrats are against school
choice
the republicans are pushing school
choice like charter schools among others
your reaction to this and what do you
think is the
the way to go the the right way
the way to go is for our school system
to actually enter the information age
maria
and by using that what you want to do is
actually create an economy for education
you see parents need to have the
purchasing power to place their children
in the environment that works best for
them that's something my own mother did
for me and that's something that
countless mothers across the united
states
and fathers for that matter want to do
for their children the days of
being trapped by your zip code being
locked into a public school system
that has a top-down approach where
there's no flexibility that actually
doesn't reward and treat
the fact that children learn differently
those days are over
we have to have an academic system that
actually lets parents choose
because they know what is best for their
children not government
not bureaucrats so congressman i mean
this is only one issue of several issues
that are in contrast
when you look at the two sides approach
assess the agenda the biden agenda
we've got obviously the coven 19 the
covid
uh package 1.9 trillion dollar package
and we're waiting on another package
which will include higher taxes not to
mention
the border disaster what strikes you
most about the biden agenda
this is one of the most progressive
agendas we've ever seen in the united
states
have you wondered why bernie sanders
isn't saying anything why aoc isn't
saying anything
is because they are very happy with the
direction that joe biden is going
which means it's bad for americans and
it's bad for america
joe biden ran on this platform it didn't
make much sense but he ran on this
platform of
trying to save the democracy but what
we're seeing up here on capitol hill is
he's destroying the republic
no other president has ever signed 50
executive actions and orders
nancy pelosi is taking bills from her
office directly to the floor
bypassing all committees our the
american people aren't even allowed in
the nation's capital maria
this is not the way our republic is
supposed to function
our republic is of the people by the
people and for the people
not for by somebody from delaware or
somebody from san francisco
and that is exactly what's happening
it's a destructive agenda
for our country meanwhile she's calling
her
election changes her reform bill for the
people
i keep saying it should be called for
the politicians what is your view on
hr1 your view is exactly right listen if
you're gonna give politicians a six to
one match
of taxpayer dollars for contributions
listed lower than two hundred dollars
or all you're going to do is empower
politicians
if you take away voter id which has been
passed in 33 states
which most americans actually support
all you care about is having rampant
chaos
in our election process not to mention
bringing in this radical agenda of
ballot harvesting
and ignoring signature verification what
we should do in our election system is
let states decide what the rules are
and when the elections are over we do
need to have a serious conversation
and strict metrics around ballot
integrity and about ballot security so
that the counts are done quickly
efficiently
so all americans have comfort that we
have a great election system here in the
united states
well i think you make a great point
because you need to ensure that people
believe in the system and do not
mistrust what's gone on congressman
love to talk to you again please come
back soon we love having you tonight
thank you sir
thank you maria have a great evening